où les plaies hasard parce que vous
l'avez vu par hasard
non parce que son père s'appelait azor
on pouvait prendre un pied dehors d'eux
se trouvait simple hasard
je vais l'appeler radar à cause de ça
que je crois que l'antenne
c'est tout ce que j'ai à vous proposer
comme les finesses et à nouveau il très
gentil enfin ce sont des chiens brûle en
principe ces chiens sont très
intelligents les très utile
finalement il était sûr vis en
définitive il regarde pas la porte
l'action n'a pas bien fait un petit tour
va me voir doutait les tasses et l'inde
c'est pas possible parce que le travail
de tournage monture alors soit on décide
je trouve ici je suis venu me demander
gentiment il aime courir les rues de
saint germain beaucoup un jour à une et
trois heures après ce que je sais pas
quoi je commençais à m'inquiéter donc
partir en voiture vont chercher chez eux
ou sur les chaînes
là j ai trouvé entre deux voitures en
train de s'expliquer sexuellement a tu
peux la télévision pourriez ce moment
avec une petite chienne de la chaîne
d'une gardienne du mode histoire en face
et comme cette gardienne nes mais à sa
chaîne en deux ans sur la tête
alors j'ai vu un un petit noeud écossais
très chic qui manoeuvrait un petit peu
et c'est sûr sur le riz 10 ans connu que
j'ai découvert en alsace en train de
raconter cette histoire à cette cliente
ça m'a fait beaucoup rire parce que en
fait si vous voulez on avait
l'impression
dans le rapport sexuel entre un monsieur
qui avait un peu baissé son pantalon en
dix ans linden qui avait gardé son
chapeau la fleur
c'est quelle race açores comme disait ma
mise pour les prix des coloniaux de
brighton cendre vous aimez les chiens de
race dijoux bah moi je le sais j'ai
toujours eu des chiens dans les films
jeux toujours fait tourner les chiens
parce que c'est une bonne heure et a bon
équilibre entre les gens et les animaux
et dans mon nom que j'avais beaucoup
tient que les besoins de cette chaîne de
rue pour vous emmener et j'ai été
chercher ces chiens la fourrière
il a bien fallu que je m'occupe moi moi
même des chiens sans quoi y aucune
raison qui reste devant la caméra
à vous tous au moins autour de la caméra
je suis occupé de 6,8 cher pour tourneur
il restait très naturel c'est pas des
chiens dressés car en fait jouer c'est
la différence qu'il ya entre côté
naturel des acteurs donc dans le cas des
chiens de deux quartiers un finish
et puis le chien tir qui est tout en
garde à vous qui attend tout le temps
les ordres de son maître c'est pas du
tout pareil évidemment voilà diana qui a
suivi qui suivent licol de mime comme
marceau et puis les autres qui vont
faire leur petit besoin nous ça leur
fait plaisir comme la démonstration et à
la fin du film donc il fallait s'en
débarrasser
ah oui alors l'oeuvre que je lui ai dit
le producteur a dit ben oui permet de
payer 40 remblier les chiens fourrière
gmail écoutez franchement ce pur
possible
moi je me suis attaché ses chiens ils
sont attachés tout le connaissait public
technique d'ailleurs tous les matins
arriver disait bonjour à tout le monde
vos cheveux
ingénieur du son pour vous connaissez il
était très heureux avec nous j'ai eu
l'idée de faire passer une annonce dans
un journal du soir
ils ont que les chiens livre dette alors
veillez lamoureux dette car c'était
volet wii qui avait tourné dans le film
mon nom ait été mis à disposition de
gens qui croyez-vous qu'ils seraient
susceptibles d'intéresser d'avoir un
petit chien ça a été fabuleux parce que
nous avons reçu tellement de demandes et
des bonnes femmes se bousculent et alors
et ils ont été répartis dans tout paris
alors dans nos analyses sont installés
avenue du bois très chic dépassé par la
minière du chien élégant il y en a un
autre qui s'est retrouvé avec un petit
retraité dans un type un pavillon
asnières qui sûrement a pris sa retraite
avec son maître et j'ai regrettés parce
que en fait tu pouvais sortir au moins
une trentaine quarantaine de chiens de
de la société protectrice des animaux en
disant que j'aurais pas été très honnête
ne va pas enfin c'était le pedigree
jacques tête ayant quelques cents là il
avait nommé bon le mieux parce que
l'autre il fera une chose c'est pour
parce que moi je les ai tourné c'est
parce que j'étais devenu des artistes de
cinéma
avant 1 heure dans votre vie vous avez
eu d'autres d'autres animaux ont
toujours eu un décor les chaînes aux
trans plus à une phrase pour moi c'est
important
10 heures parce qu'ils sont très fidèles
et aujourd'hui est certain que fidélité
quelque chose qui touche
particulièrement
est-ce que ça remonte à l'enfance même
salle un tout petit jeu le tout kg moi
j'ai toujours eu en forme devant mon
père également des chiens et loyers
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant de voir
l'école communale et par loin d'ici et
si je suis avec hazard les enfants
s'arrêtent et bien tout le temps caressé
ils ont besoin de donner un peu
d'affection